la histerectomía es la extirpación
quirúrgica del útero
cuando también se extirpan los ovarios
y las trompas de falopio se denomina
histerectomía con saltimbanco fue recto
mía
una histerectomía se realiza con el
propósito de tratar el cáncer del
útero los fibroides uterinos
la endometriosis
el prolapso uterino y otras afecciones
ginecológicas
cuando usted llega al hospital para
someterse a la cirugía se le colocará
una vía intravenosa
si se le va a practicar una
histerectomía abdominal es posible que
él era su en la zona púbica y
abdominal
las histerectomías se pueden realizar
con anestesia general por local
si recibe anestesia general estará
dormido durante todo el procedimiento y
se insertará temporalmente un tubo
respiratorio por la boca y en la
garganta para ayudarla a respirar
durante la operación
se le colocará un catéter en la vejiga
para drenar la orina durante la cirugía
una histerectomía durante unas tres
horas
existen tres formas principales de hacer
esta cirugía por el día domina el
por vía vaginal
o por vía vaginal asistida con
laparoscopía
para una histerectomía abdominal el
cirujano realizará una incisión en el
abdomen inferior
retirar a los músculos para exponer el
útero
cortará los ligamentos y tejidos que
sostienen el útero en su lugar
y es que para el útero a través de la
incisión abdominal
si el procedimiento incluye unas al pin
conflicto mía
el cirujano extirpar a los ovarios y las
trompas de falopio de la misma forma
para realizar una histerectomía vaginal
se inserta un espéculo pesado en la
vagina para estirarla y mantener la
dieta
el cirujano realizará una incisión
internarse de dos del cuello del útero
cortará los ligamentos y tejidos que
sostienen el útero en su lugar
y deslizara el útero por la vagina
para una histerectomía vaginal asistida
con laparoscopia el cirujano crearán
varias incisiones pequeñas denominadas
puertos de entrada en el abdomen
luego se bombeará dióxido de carbono a
través del puerto de entrada umbilical
para inflar en la tomen y así poder
visualizar su contenido más fácilmente
el cirujano insertará un laparoscopio
por uno de los puestos
las imágenes de la cámara se proyectan
en un monitor de la sala de operaciones
observando el monitor el cirujano
deslizara herramientas quirúrgicas
especializadas por los otros puertos y
las utilizará para realizar una
incisión alrededor del cuello del
útero
liberará al útero de los tejidos y
ligamentos que lo sostienen
y no pasará por la vagina
un laparoscopio también se puede
utilizar para unas al pingo fue recto
mía
finalmente el cirujano cerrará las
incisiones en el abdomen con puntos
en los tres procedimientos de
histerectomía la parte superior de la
página se sutura y se coloca un
taponamiento de gas en la vagina para
evitar el sangrado en exceso
después de la cirugía se la llevara al
área de recuperación para su monitoreo
el catéter y el taponamiento de casa se
retirarán antes de que abandone el
hospital